[Music]
in band for good news submitted by hi
Gio TIF and Nikki Oh a man reports a
staggering weight loss after his trainer
gets him banned from fast-food
restaurants that guy went above and
beyond man he actually did it for free
he coached him and like this whole time
and he lost a whole bunch of weight and
the coach didn't charge him at all he
forgot - huh but did you hear about
Jordan SIA he tried a Big Mac a day for
30 days and he lost seven pounds what is
just one big mess
I mean maybe but I think he ate normally
he just counted his mattress and because
he's counting macro he wanted to prove
oh I don't know exactly what he did but
he wanted to prove that like you can
still lose weight on cheap - oh yeah
yeah where you can ban yourself in fast
food restaurants what do you do take a
crap inside of McDonald's on the floor
or something
no it's trainer bendin no sir well I
mean I counted he get banned bad or is
it just he's not allowed to go cuz he
asked C because he really wants to know
in you and that would be like hours long
compilation of every time I try to say
some oh my god so uh please make your
typical tip but no words just
interruption included look natural I
wish you could have so many copies okay
so the way his trainer did it is by
sending out flyers to all Dipsy oh wow
that guy's big new local fast food
restaurants like his favorite fast food
restaurant it's awesome voluntarily
agreed to this obviously - what size
shirt
10th that's like a banshee
that's a [ __ ] that's like a that's
like a Mickey do you ought to keep that
doing start the apology right now or I
said it you guys [ __ ] just I said it
oh the the flyer by the way it said save
Dipsy of obesity is killing him do not
serve this man and so what a dope
trainer amazing mike is the trainer
Dipsy darren AKA Dipsy he's the one oh
good that lost all the weight and so he
actually lost 280 pounds amazing made
that benchmark he was able to weigh in
like nine days before the year how come
you look better fast you had more hair
when he was better it was a bad picture
it was dark I just feel this relief for
him yeah the Train is cute yeah why is
this trainer look kind of fine now he
looks familiar
don't look at him don't flirt with the
trainer okay so if you go to that other
picture was so dark it looked like he
lost weight but he turned into a grandpa
ah
if you buddy the marathon I think so
yeah damn you did a marathon I wanted a
marathon before him man that's currently
imagine how good his body feels cuz when
I was pregnant I gained what like 40 or
50 pounds and your joints your feet
everything just [ __ ] the hurt my game
I 60 pounds 50 or 60 wasn't matter ten
pound difference oh yeah yeah so the
point being I was just had a lot heavier
than what I was normally used to do in
front of me no so yeah after I lost the
baby weight or whatever yeah I just felt
like this big like relief
it was never gonna go away my game forty
pounds and I was like I'm gonna be like
this that was like double your weight
basically [ __ ] yeah it was yeah it was
95 before I got think oh my gosh it's
like 50 perceived he lost to a Michael
Jackson to 80 pounds and he's still bad
he's 20 years old that means probably
I'm not saying anything bad though maybe
starting on like five or six I didn't
get to finish my sentence so he lost 280
pounds he's still fat right so but how
many pounds does he still have left over
I'm just trying to figure out when he
looked like his when his band picture
how much was he there like four hundred
they don't tell me actually I don't know
exact it's gotta be five or six because
he looks like a tall dude so you know
you they do sorry what is it 565
something dude yeah like if you if you
if you lost to something right and he
still looks about to something he looks
still almost maybe even three that's why
I was just like that's crazy so back
when I mean not to knock that he lost
weight I'm just like saying like yeah he
is overweight yes 600 pounds of people
that like they have to be airlifted out
of there
like back then he was taking in around
11,000 calories a day which is enough to
feed a family of six that's so delicious
or make a really good YouTube video yeah
eleven thousand calories Hewitt so
they're saying that a year ago you would
often start his day with a full English
breakfast before having a pastry and pie
what they wrote up for Lewis rec this is
mash really beans in the tomato
delicious how often do you order it cuz
it's so [ __ ] delicious cuz they don't
make it right over here
but you ain't even you can get my tomato
don't play my culture and asses over
there I always get that he's so cultured
you should subscribe if you're over
there in the UK or if you're here and
laughter anywhere in the world with the
computer you should subscribe I heard it
it helps with weight loss when you
subscribe to JK news I heard all over in
Japan I always got the English breakfast
with the tomatoes and they made it
pretty good it's really good yeah and
then at dinnertime Hugh would eat fish
and chips or Indian takeout and wash it
down with a large bottle of puppet
tournesol Stephanie followed by ice
cream yeah how did he afford this diet
what does he do for a living that's
crazy but Mike the his trainer he said
that his services would have cost a
paying customer about sixty one thousand
dollars for the whole year what he gave
him because he gave a look to three
one-on-one private sessions a day and
all of his food some Biggest Loser but
just him yeah why didn't this guy the
trainer guy pick him like did he just
like it was like what's a call when
lawyers do it for free paavo no it was
like that like cuz he just felt like he
wanted to save this guy's life so yeah
and he's got some good marketing worth
day what's his name give him a shout-out
Mike and I feel the same way if I was a
trainer and he did man cuz that's that's
just like unique like it's not every day
that someone walks in and they actually
want to make make a difference yeah and
they're down to like I'll follow
everything you say he was saying that um
so Dixie was saying that there were so
many warnings like you just did not want
to get out of bed but mike has been
there to push him the whole way through
and he's been absolutely incredible and
like I could imagine I mean like there's
skinny ass people that can't get out of
bed imagine having four hundred plus
pounds it's even harder to get out of
bed yeah
like literally I seen those talk shows
where they had to [ __ ] bust down the
wall and then pull that pool like a
obese person out of a [ __ ] dolly yeah
and they're safe three pounds like you
eat that like five six yeah I saw this
one where they were doing a show on
obese people and they had to get like a
huge kiddie pool thing to take a tub a
shower because they couldn't fit in the
tub
like the dad was he had dish soap and he
was using that [ __ ] my god
push pourings dish soap on the Sun with
a scrubber like it was it look like she
was bathing a cow I was like that's
crazy man second half is great because
it's like with skinny people not wanting
to get out of bed like there's so many
days where I don't want to go to the gym
and I love that [ __ ] this is motivating
though imagine the gym is in my garage
so you don't want to go to garage I'm
like I don't even want to do it today so
I can imagine especially with that much
weight like yeah your joints hurt like
it hurts to move yeah because you're
carrying around 600 pounds with you just
by walking down stairs or to the kitchen
or across the hall that just goes to
show how important it is to have that
support of someone always there like get
your ass up and someone who yeah they're
there they're like they start like
pushing you telling you come on man you
can do this and then like mentally if
you're just not there that day you have
that person that's like helping you well
but wait did you ever go to the
McDonald's and they were like nah man we
can't give you anything I don't know
that'll be [ __ ] dope if it actually
worked
yeah maybe there were times moments of
weakness where he just ended up going
and they're like I wonder like how
strong he is from like carrying all that
around and now he doesn't have to carry
all that around like he's carrying
around 300 pounds less does it work that
way okay how does that work yes in haste
he probably has a good amount of muscle
mass because yeah he's like carrying
resistance he's resisting he's already
working out carrying his body but one
time I dated this guy and he was a
bigger guy not that big but he was a
bigger guy and we broke up and he had
like a weight loss transformation and he
was [ __ ] ripped and you were like
dammit
why couldn't you look like that before
haha but I think he was I think he was
doing steroids to be honest because all
my friends were like there's no way that
with Andre
they're like there's no way but I
remember he like I was like wait you
look a lot different like in a span of a
couple months that sounds about steroid
ROI he would have some muscle under
there but also with being that size I'm
sure he has a lot of loose skin so like
in the photos I mean I don't know how
much it is now but he probably has so
much loose skin so that maybe he appears
to be bigger than he's bigger than what
he would be a few was just we have a
friend who's just going through this
crazy weight loss journey and he's
boasting a ton of videos Doughboy away
yeah and and he's there with his shirt
off and you can see just like the
sagginess cuz of how fast he lost like
and it's just it's hanging or not even
or I mean I don't know but I'm assuming
no matter how long it would have taken
for him to lose that weight just losing
that weight period would have caused
excess skin cuz for Dipsy that he said
they're saying that he's gonna undergo
three surgeries to have the excess skin
removed and he's hoping to have the
first one done in December so I'm just
like it looks bad but it actually feels
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]